some have described with the Oakland
Raiders are up to this year as a
chemistry experiment I would say it's
more like a Frankenstein monster a bunch
of mismatched parts thrown together
under the supervision of dr.
Frankenstein also known as Jon Gruden
who is trying to get the most out of
this machine that is being put together
on the fly in the hopes that the Raiders
can compete with the likes of the Chiefs
the charges in the Broncos in the AFC
West it's not going to be an easy thing
to do
now Antonio Brown arrives from
Pittsburgh they traded for him they got
him for a steal but they paid him more
money and he supposedly is going to pump
up the offense and look if he doesn't
here's the thing it's not gonna be his
faults not gonna be John Burton's fault
it's gonna be the quarterbacks fault
this all comes back to Derek Carr and I
remember when Jon Gruden took the job as
Raiders head coach when his name first
came up as a candidate to succeed Jack
Del Rio in Oakland there was a concern
that Derek Carr would not be able to
take Jon Gruden would not be able to
tolerate the aggressive and relentless
coaching of Jon Gruden I think Gruden
has adapted his style to fit with cars
personality and I don't think Rudin
really likes that I really do believe
deep down that the Raiders are looking
for a new brain for their Frankenstein
monster and that brain for an NFL team
is a quarterback and I have a feeling
that if Derek Carr doesn't step up this
year and I'm not saying he won't and I'm
not saying I'm rooting that he doesn't
all I'm saying is if he doesn't step up
and if he doesn't perform better and if
he doesn't get the most out of Antonio
Brown and if the Raiders don't win more
than five or six games they're gonna go
to Las Vegas without Derek Carr as their
quarterback I firmly believe that it and
mike Mayock the GM of the team basically
acknowledged they are on the lookout for
an upgrade at the quarterback position
when he explained why they had worked
out Kyler's murray and dwayne Haskins
prior to the draft he could have said
well you know what there's a chance we
may be in position to trade for these
guys so we need to know what we think of
them so we can set a proper value on
what we would want for the fourth
overall pick that would allow someone to
come up and get Murray if he had still
been there or Haskins who was still
there that's what Mayo could have said
but what he said instead was hey we're
always looking to improve every position
on the team including quarterbacks so
Derek and I know that Derek has since
said hey he's going to be the
quarterback of the Raiders as long as he
wants to be no the only way that's going
to happen is if the Raiders want you to
be the quarterback for a long as long as
you want to be and that's the thing to
watch this year as these pieces come
together as the Raiders try to make
their last year in Oakland a special one
all eyes need to be on Derek Carr
whether or not he can run the offense
whether or not he can score points
whether or not the team can win games
because if it doesn't work he's the one
who's getting thrown under the bus and
he's the one who's not going to be on
the bus that's gonna roll to Las Vegas
after this season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports